we live on two levels a higher level and
a lower level higher level is where the
goddess is and that's where we're trying
to get as artists we're trying to get
there and then come back and and deliver
the goods author Stephen pressfields
books have earned him worldwide Acclaim
he's a novelist a screenwriter former
U.S marine his books have inspired and
motivated millions of readers around the
world but his personal story is just as
inspiring when did you discover this
idea of muse I think I was maybe 32
something and I would go visit a friend
of mine down the street and he
introduced this idea to me that when you
sit down to write you're kind of
entering a Sacred Space you say a prayer
to the goddess I'm here to work for you
help me you know and over time my belief
and understanding of this has only
deepened and she has never let me down
[Music]
thank you